my name is Andy I'm a chief scientist at
continuum analytics my background is
Pete Travis talked about was high
performance computing doing
computational mathematics and I also
helped run the num focus foundation and
so I have experience and a whole bunch
of different vectors and whatnot but
moving on because I'm boring so
continuing on analytics just to give you
a little bit of understanding of who we
are what we do is so we build
technologies that enable analyst and
data scientist to answer questions then
the questions are all around us and we
come from the open source community
which means that we were highly
dedicated open source code and if you
are peruse through the schedule today
you will see a whole host of our open
source code being demonstrated
throughout throughout the day so what
does that mean for most people at some
company you have a terabyte of data
laying around and where the guy's help
you explore it and we do it through a
full stack of different tools from
anaconda which gives you about 21 of
different packages to easily install
condom which will allow you to manage
your environments and do package
managing number compiler to speed up
Python blaze which I'll talk a little
bit about to scale to massive amounts of
data and we have a couple of the plays
chord devs here in the room and bouquet
which will help you get those pretty
plots of cats into your browser because
that's what we all want to do really and
then at the end of the day we have to
share and deploy our code with the car
so that's kind of the continuum suite of
stacks but today my goal is to talk
about this in Hadoop so great you have a
jerk with a lot of titles and a stack of
software to sell you so how do what do i
do too so what kind of problems do I saw
so in I came from computational
scientists so we took equations like
these and solved okay this video is that
video play all right
and took so what I used to say problems
math equations to this and this is
supposed to be a little gift that shows
a wave going back and forth to solve on
your desktop and take them to the
massive scaling machines like this in
the corner and my slides are all messed
up here very sorry to the machines like
this which is 6000 nodes of very highly
very dense memory and compute machines
running up to I think 25,000 processes
to solve problems that look like that
where you have a storm surge coming in
and you want to know if your city is
going to be underwater so that's the
problems i use to solve thank you very
much and so the question is what why is
this interesting to Hadoop well it turns
out now the problems i solve start with
HTML files and free text go to machines
that look like this which is literally
if you google image Hadoop cluster that
is what you get I'm not trying to be
pejorative I'm just I'm just represent
Google here using the wonderful
scikit-learn tools and other the other
pieces of the pie cut Python ecosystem
to get out an understanding of that data
coming in to solve problems like human
trafficking and find out where a bowl of
spreading and things like that so going
from big math to big data is kind of my
transition in life and why I'm here
talking to you about Python I have to do
all right so what am I actually really
here to talk about first I want to go
through a little bit of a discussion
about where the Hadoop system is where
python is in that Hadoop system and then
we had with time cut a little bit short
just because we had all the people
coming up downstairs is we're going to
try and end on time so I'll probably
briefly go through blaze I'm bouquet and
how you interact with the Hadoop system
with those open source tools so first
let's talk about the ecosystem so large
scale data analytics our view of the
world comes to in four different areas
we have bi tools distributed systems a
scientific computing like I showed you
the very beginning and then stats a
machine learning
and domain modeling so first I have a
lot of people in the finance world love
their bi tools they stare at them all
day you can see screens of numbers at
high density so we have to work with
things like my sequel or [ __ ] and and
interact with the standard bi tools
because that's how you get on to those
gooeys that you have eight screens and
finance financial folks can destroy our
market which is a good thing second we
have tons of tools to do machine
learning and here we have a psych it
will have scikit-learn toxin pandas
talks later on today and so how do we
actually get these things to work and a
lot of these guys are built on top of
scientific computing tools which is
where I came from with for example numpy
which Travis built so long ago and new
things like beat calls which gives us a
very fast interface to the disk disk
storage compress this storage and now
the new kind of kids in town of
distributed systems using Hadoop spark
hive and things like high of an Impala
the interaction with these traditionally
goes something like this where the
distributed systems talk to your bi
tools and you have nice queries and
maybe you pull out that data from that
nice query and pipe it over to pandas or
scikit-learn and from that you might
talk to a scientific computing stack but
very rarely did you actually talk have
the scientific computing sec actually
talked to the distributed system inside
the hadoop world now in the MPI world in
the supercomputing world you did that
backwards you always went to the the
distributed system first and now we have
a few places or trying to cross over
like my hope and our Hadoop and things
like that but from the machine learning
side to the spark systems and whatnot so
what kind of our Kyle sorry animations
so that architecture there has been
often turned into something like the
lambda architecture and I usually show
the slides so people kind of know what
we're talking about where you have batch
layers serving layers and speed layers
so I stream data in and I usually go to
that top layer with all the interesting
things happen at least for me and I do a
lot of Hadoop processing and a lot of
data processing and that comes back into
a serving Larry into a database or
however you might prefer your data of
course there's always a lot of people in
the room I'll speak a little bit about
parsley tools and that want to go
straight to that that stream layer and
just speed through and see incremental
updates throughout so that bottom layer
kind of takes us to the speed layer
there's a lot of different systems out
there that are providing this kind of
land of architecture for example you
have the base Hadoop stack which you
kind of a whole zoo there with a CFS
high of HBase and whatnot and then
there's the Berkeley data science stack
which if you don't know the I think it's
pronounced badass stack at least that's
what they call it and so I always
enjoyed that but here they've taken a
lot of the Hadoop layer and replaced it
with things that we know are much faster
like adding spark and tachyon which
gives you a distributed caching layer
and then having seen a single stack that
on top of that uses scholar which could
be a you know a much nicer way to
program but also do streaming and and
there's this is a little old slide but
you have like sequel api's and things
like that and so but so there's lots of
stacks lots of different ways people are
interacting that but where exactly is
Python in this world and so Python ends
up being in several different places the
first one is kind of Python as a driver
so we see so today if you go ask around
the 20 different people you get 30
different answers but they'll all say at
least these three right pi spark which
is a really great layer how many people
have used by spark in the room how many
people have used spark in the room how
many people use Hadoop in the room how
many people use a computer in the room
all right that guy's asleep there you go
raise your hand all right there we go
he's okay so if you've used if you use a
computer go use PI spark it's amazing
that's what it will get you they used to
talk about how wonderful you could get
this year computing up in PI spark is
the closest thing I've ever seen to go
from a single script to a really
distributed computing script MapReduce
kind of promised us that and they never
realized oh wait this is hard to use PI
spark is actually a lot nicer to use you
load up your txt file it just kind of
very nicely the second thing that people
talk about is to do streaming how many
people have used cat okay how many
people know what kit well how many
people know what cat is how many people
use unix okay all right so cat is a unix
tool that just streams out a file right
so do streaming is just stream out a
file into another program we've all used
python so that's good into an end to a
text file and we've all used text files
that's all you have to know to use
Hadoop streaming cat a file into a file
and put it into straight into another
file and so Hadoop streaming is another
really nice way to take a single very
small script to do that sort of thing
but it is at a very granular level right
a single script that I can put in and
emulate on my desktop as if it were Cat
Cat Python program file and that's a
it's a very nice kind of UNIX system but
the same time once again it's it's not
really designed to solve these large
distributed problems or these large
highly coupled parallel problems and
then there's pig which is because
Hadoop's hard when it developed a
dataflow language called pig reaching
and then put in a really nice python
scripts inside of those although once
again same limitations of Hadoop
streaming the next kind of area where a
lot of people are using Hadoop and
python is the Python as the UDF driver
and so UDF just stands for user-defined
function typically you think of like for
example a postgres a sequel hooker like
a trigger that where you store a
function into the into the database and
then whenever something happens it fires
off that database for certain calls and
whatnot it's always been a very nice
concept but you would always say well
why do I need a store Python into the
database when I can just call pandas and
actually manipulate it as if it were a
script so it's always been something
that's not super compelling for me until
you get to a system where your database
is actually distribute through the
entire four nodes that we saw or 20,000
though is if you're too
and so there's two there's two of the
bigger codes I know oven there's there's
obviously a lot more but to that we kind
of worked one when we worked with it
with in pot cloud errors and Paula which
is a database engine built on top of
HDFS and they actually took our number
based tool that speeds up Python and
produces a llvm code block forum and can
so any Python code can be compiled from
number and run inside the database so
then it will be very easy way to fire up
a throw in all your sequel data and then
fire up a Python script inside the
database that actually runs distributed
over the entire cluster the other way to
do this is hive is a little more
traditional I'm told that it's um it
leaves a lot of speed on the table so I
usually point people to compile up but
if you have the the latest hortonworks
Oh distribution you realize that oh
that's clubbed error and we have to use
Hortonworks hive is your answer so and
hive does the same a very similar thing
although they they run a native python
that serializes instead of using kind of
a code injection like in Pilot us all
right but what about that speed layer we
just talked about and so I want to take
a few moments to talk a little bit about
whoo-hoo-hoo you go talk to about that
that bottom layer and there's basically
two two different codes that I use a
park sleaze stream parse which uses a
patchy storm so how many people know
Apache storm is okay a good number so
patchy storm is a a parson there is a
stream manager that takes a they call
them sprouts and bolts and so you write
little bolt programs that then produce
spouts and those go into a new boat
program so think of it as a fractal
Hadoop streaming if you will and so
parsley has a really nice coat for
setting this up and I definitely
recommend going and checking out their
stream parts and they have a whole
topology and things like that so any
data coming in you throw it into your
storm topology a thing goes with your
map producer your cluster workers and
then goes out to your different files
and whatnot and parsley stool
amazing one to use then there's Kafka
which how many people know Kafka is ok
so I really should have spent a lot more
time going through all these tools so
Kafka is a log commit as a log manager
that basically takes another stream and
commits it to a global log and then
create streams off of that global log
and so Kafka Python it has a really nice
protocol if you have a huge amounts of
data I guess the big point of the story
there is that Kafka command it Kafka can
manage if you have data that you can't
actually really process because you just
have so much some free Apple have lots
of spurts of data coming at me Kafka is
the thing you want to use because it can
handle that spurts of data than once
that spirit of data kind of dies out
then your your speed layer your bachelor
can take care of it a lot more and so by
just focusing a single log and then then
bring pipes out of that log you get the
same sort of speed the cool thing about
these guys are both reproducible so if i
have a stream and I I want to run this
code again I produce another stream it
will run the same code which is a really
cool feat if you ever want to read a
really neat paper about how that's done
the Apache storm paper on storing
triples and Frank getting
reproducibility out of these large
streaming systems is very cool ok so
that's kind of my view of some of the
codes you should know about in the
Python ecosystem and I want to kind of
go into kind of how we use these things
at Austin there in continual so so it's
great all I see his pictures what does
this really do for me so me being
someone who doesn't want to do any work
I sale hey Jeannie give me a Hadoop Bob
and and then that didn't really work so
we built this code called anaconda
cluster so anaconda cluster is a new
product it a continuum that basically
takes the Anaconda stack and we'll load
it up on your cluster for you so all the
things you do in a condo where you
create your entire environment and your
Python ecosystem saying you want which
packages you want it basically will help
you deploy on that cluster and it works
something like this i say Conda please
create me a demo cluster and for the
example here I say
give me a simple a AWS with three nodes
and I can even tell you which size a
machine i want for AWS and it works for
devotion some other things and i can
give for example of a image in this case
the simple image like that and that that
guy goes and spins up us suspends us up
spark cluster and which also runs cdh so
you can run hive and HBase and other
things on as well so great what do I do
with that I ask the genie to give me a
useful cluster and what is a useful
cluster for the purpose of this demo
we're going to find that as anaconda
plus numba so I talked to look so
everybody knows what anaconda is right
okay there we go everybody's shaking it
awesome that's what I like to hear and I
talked a little bit of numba maybe maybe
we should talk a little bit more so
number basically takes Python code you
add a jit flag to it and it turns it
into llvm code which is pretty nice
because llvm works pretty much
everywhere these days Thank You Apple
and we can hit if you buy the pro
version right you get to work on GPUs
and fancy architectures and whatnot but
if nothing else you can use the standard
version and believe Jake van der plazas
examples of getting 1500 x speed up and
things like that I don't think that was
this code but it was something like it
right and so here for example you can do
a real kind of interesting updates to
very large matrices and things like that
although we're just doing three by
threes here so that's what number does
takes Python numpy code Bruce's llvm
code so the first thing I say is I say
conduct cluster please manage my cluster
so I have to we have this wait we
haven't completely figured out the the
CLI to this thing but we it'll get
better so I tell it give me a demo
costume please create me a test
environment and on that I say give me
Python give me an umpire give me number
and so on and so forth and then i say
jeanie makes mark faster and so i'll put
these slides up later so you can study
this just in much detail and so we have
a gist of using spark in number inside a
spark routine
and that and let me go through kind of
the interesting parts right now so first
you create a spark context so all this
guy does is go and sets up an appt and
sets up your machine and tells tell us a
machine like I'm taking over and
whenever you do what not I have so mu F
and eateries and partitions or numbers
that come down from a function so I
create some matrices on this function I
have some random matrix I create and I
broadcast those matrices throughout my
cluster so this broadcast just puts it
throughout the cluster there and so then
I say I have two parallel eyes this this
function here and so I say paralyzed
this map into these partitions map this
update function with a whole bunch of
values and we'll talk about this update
and at the end of that I will have a
matrix M ass that I can then broadcast
throughout and then paralyzed another
matrix computation but this guy is doing
is doing ALS which is an alternative
alternating at least squares that's what
it was and so the alternating least
squares basically take it's going to
have a couple of matrix multiplies and
reduction or matrix vectors which is
usually the level I think of anyways so
this is what the update guy looks like
so i have my matrix transpose matrix on
the on the right side here and you
notice here matrix multiply well that's
done pretty well by numpy especially if
you have the MPL bindings everything set
up in your cluster which kind of the
cluster kind of comes with typically or
at least when I set it up then you have
your non linear updates and this was
where we actually had the JIT code so
all we're actually getting is this code
right here because everything else in
this code is basically math right so we
can use low-level blahs libraries and
things like that but there's that one
update function if you try to paralyze
that guy it ends up being I think on the
order of
sixty percent of our time and so we were
able to speed up this one function by I
think several orders are well I think
one order of magnitude so several times
but they'll be eating up the whole thing
okay like I think two times or something
like that and so in here we just jit add
and we actually add into this function a
lambda which is a parameter that comes
through the function and that you you
which came from our XTX the transpose
guy there so this is an example of how
to use these things so you can very
easily go in manipulate in a simple
Python manner but then you can get any
code that is kind of the slow part of
Python typically and all of a sudden you
have a very very natural way of working
with this code this code isn't so bad
you have to do a few bits of imaginative
broadcast things out but then you can
just go into your update function and
you're off to the races of pi spark and
using spark and the entire ecosystem all
right so then the other kind of
challenging part to this is how do I
actually run this guy because there's at
least 10 different ways to run in in a
dupe where they're using yarn or may so
sore or whatnot and so our cluster will
launch the script with a very kind of
launch the script on this cluster with
whatever we name the script and whatnot
justice this is actually works we made a
demo video and since I'm not marrying my
screen
and so the script works something like
this so we create the cluster playing
let's not play
it's like I created a video so it when I
wouldn't have like a problem with it so
more or less you so you create a cluster
and it goes off and does the it uses lib
cloud to interface with the cloud
computing environment so it does work on
any environment that we can get lib
cloud to work on including in-house
environments and whatnot and so this
actually takes a little bit of time to
to work so we have another window that
will open up here never mind that and so
all right so finally we get salt coming
coming up and we start setting up the
machine and so on and it'll go through
and set up very large machines or very
small machines as this case goes and
we're testing a lot on AWS just so this
this code is still in beta we're still
testing out a lot we hope to release
something for open-source folks to use
within the couple of days and so it's
just a kind of command you upload with
Conda and for example I say except I
register some clusters with it and you
can do kind of commands the list the
different clusters we have for example
there's a PI data demo I think Matt
might be using later today although I
don't think he's using this tool and so
so we're still setting up that machine
now we can you look at this guy and
basically all we're doing is saying give
me some IP addresses and you can even
tell me what the providers are and what
you actually want on a machine inside
the CMO file it just sits alongside your
kind of artsy file the next thing we
kind of do is show how to set
environments here let me make this
bigger here just so there's a help
command we have for example list infoset
environments create kind of in the
bootstrap is kind of like I just want to
bootstrap a mini kind of cluster so now
here the demo take some info on the
actually what is actually running on
that guy and see when it's up and all
right there we go we have a root install
of anaconda and opt-in
condo so now we're ready to go but I do
need to create my test environment and
so as a quick example that Python 27 and
um pie and so what this guy's going to
do is it's going to set up an
environment and then create and then
create that what packages need to be
installed and then then you'll have to
say push environment and it will then
push it out to your cluster so instead
of and okay so we're going to example a
stream a stream example as well and so
this will push it out to the cluster a
little bit out into a little bit faster
you can see how it's streaming it out to
the cluster and putting the opt and it
kind of been to four different places
and there's your standard cluster stay
in the environment for condit now it's
Conda on a cluster and when we call info
we see now we have three different
environments the root environment dev
environment dev one environment that we
can play with and so we
so we set an environment here and now
we're ready to go to start launching
clusters and this command should work of
course if everyone anyone who's ever
used a cluster you realize it doesn't
necessarily spawned as fast as you want
every day and so will we have some work
to fix some of that so that's more or
less the idea of how we kind of set up
clusters manage clusters and move to the
Hadoop ecosystem so let me start them
this is so that's an econo cluster if
you if you're interested in trying out a
beta copy definitely there's a contact
us button on the website and gore come
talk to me so that's if you actually
want to Hadoop how many people are going
to go use a dupe now oh man that that
that's that's a fail whale right there
all right so how does sane people use
this well we have two codes that blaze
and in boquete which I'll briefly go
over I don't want to steal the thunder
Matt rocklands giving a talk later about
blaze and there's Brian vandeven who I
don't think I don't see in the room will
be talking about bouquet in much more
detail i'm just going to give a very
high level overview so so in this
ecosystem you saw a lot of tools a lot
of different ways of interacting with
the data but this basically most
people's view point is is just really a
pain to use and we're definitely trying
to build tools to make it much easier
use for the python ecosystem but with
this pain we have another tool called
blaze and the basic idea of places to
build a tool that actually helps you
with your needs so as any tool you have
a something that fits the part fits the
problem you have something that fits the
the person and if you actually want to
interact with this entire I don't know
if I'm stealing your thunder Maddox I
did steal okay good these were his
slides I think
okay no all right they've came from the
drive so you so but the problem with
this ride is this is the typical idea of
like every every problem becomes a
hammer so we end up being hair and nail
and we end up with thousands of tools so
any carpenters bag you will have a whole
lot of tools now just like nobody was
interested in Hadoop in this crowd
nobody's really interested in buying all
these tools just to fix their kitchen
right here or fix their faucet and so we
have a whole ride of things so this is
fixed fits the problem now we want
something that actually fits the user
and so lots of people probably bought
the tool like this i'm guessing many
more people but this tool that i bought
all those tools on the previous page and
this is just the dremel tool right so
blazed provides a easy interface to
interact with all these tools in a way
that is nice and pluggable and actually
works throughout the python ecosystem
because we love python so to bring it
back to that very first kind of diagram
of the world of large databases large
distribute applications we have blazed
in the middle that actually talks to
these distributed systems that can push
that code that's part so I set up a
spark cluster nobody is going to use it
but if you use blaze you might actually
use it anyways because we actually do
have a lot of spark and Impala codes
inside blaze that can take the same
pandas code you ran and run it on blaze
so it becomes a very easy way to
interact with scientific computing
machine learning bi tools and whatnot to
get that same sort of system so you
don't have to learn all these tools at
once of course everybody looks at this
and they say that's a little bit magical
how in the world does that work well we
we use a very easy trick called lazy
evaluation and symbolic manipulation so
we have the blaze kind of triangles my
colleague Christine joy who may this
light likes to call it we have abstract
expressions at the top so things like
your split apply combine your filters
your projections and so on and so forth
then we have we joined those guys up
with data sources handling you know
literally hundreds of data sources all
the Python can throw at us from csv to
hdf5 to JSON and data frames and so on
and so forth those computational
backends so you might not be very
interested in using spark and using this
Ruby computing but if you had a problem
that requires that it's nice to have a
tool that can then easily transfer to
using those big machines as suppose a
only your desktop and that's where blaze
can come in and transfer your pandas
code to a spark code and I'll show an
example of doing that in just a minute
so that's the idea of blades to give a
architectural diagram I realize Matt's
probably thrown this away after I made
it but I view our architectures we have
an API so that everyone can hit and use
it's the same API throughout we build
deferred expressions and have an
interpreter layer that then talks to our
data layers and our compute layers we
try to keep the user away from the
computer as much as possible although
often what happens you set up something
with pandas and whatnot and then pass it
off to blaze and then we we drive it
from there we can't keep you away from
the data layer because thats everywhere
and we can't possibly get to know
everything about your data so that's
kind of the kind of baseline
architecture what we do to give an
example we had to join the web with the
web which this is a example of using the
common crawls hyperlink graph so here we
have an expression and the table symbol
is deprecated so don't use this code
anymore Gillis and Matt rockland and so
where we take the art of these arc files
that gives us the name the URL that you
will find your websites at and the node
into the graph that would then tells us
the connectivity of the graph where the
arc files that tells the connectivity of
the graph that node ID and it's out
neighbors and in neighbors and we joined
this guy based upon that node ID so it's
very simple example I hope that you all
don't get to work with only four for
rope graphs because that we can actually
or for Road tables because we can
actually do that very well so anyone
with thousands rose no yeah there we go
this one guy
right so in finance world you always
find these nice tables are usually
they're like that should be inverted
right that's not okay so this by this by
operator comes from the split up I
combine notion so it looks a lot like
our and we join on the name of that node
and we just count the rose so all this
guy is doing is going out counting how
big your footprint is on the web and for
example I load data which I'll show you
in just a minute which is the part where
you can switch from different places and
the computation says compute it figures
out what your data and your compute
system is based upon that data and then
you can have a dictionary like access to
things like how big is black spots
footprint here's and here's the load
data basically using spark in HDFS looks
a lot like the code I showed you before
I just say give me a spark context give
me a text file which is a distributed
text file map over that text file how to
actually split this thing out so that I
can read it as two numbers and I do the
same thing with the arc file or I use
pandas if I'm going on local disk so I
just open a file like you open a file in
Python as normal and I do the same thing
where I split the file say how do i read
the two numbers out of every line of
that file and so there I have by arc and
index files which then computed and this
guy worked on on my laptop and a cluster
of i think i think the clusters around
600 nodes so straight off want to learn
more go go talk to matt rockland we have
webinars and blog posts and whatnot and
i have two minutes so i will just show
bouquet and take questions the second
part of this is all right so you can use
tables you knew manipulations it can hit
a very large to do cluster what about
when I want to show those cat videos
well we have a data visualization of
library called bouquet that does novel
graphics and it's bouquet at pi dot org
and it does interactive visualizations
in your browser and can stream large
dynamic data and do an algorithm we call
abstract rendering to do incredibly
smart down sampling so if you're you
have a lot of over plotting so we just
plot big data usually just get for
example a map that's just a population
of the of the world we often have a lot
of abstract or entering so you can put
in and say hey I don't want the
population of the world I want the
difference in population the per capita
or something like that so it gives you a
much smarter way of adding abstract down
sampling and the variant and the big
thing here is no need to write
JavaScript we use map matplotlib
capability and so we don't like driving
JavaScript so we wrote a whole lot of it
so you don't have to and there's a whole
lot of kind of nice visualizations I
think Quran is also going to show using
some really nice widgets it as well and
building dashboards and very functional
kind of things go see Brian to see
what's cool and what's up up-to-date go
see chronic sancya a grant in the in the
field views on this thing all right so
here's some more kind of visualizations
of it thank you very much for your time
and I think I have time for at least one
question